and
as people roll in I'm going to put a
message into the chat for them about
putting their questions into the Q a
Karthik was asking me a moment ago where
people are joining the session from so
if you want to go ahead and put into the
chat
where you're located
that'll be great we'd love to find out
more about you
South Africa wow
welcome
Nigeria
almati
in Kazakhstan
Uganda
Morocco
India
welcome everyone
Tanzania
okay
and we'll be starting in just under a
minute so
as a reminder if you have questions
please put them in the Q a box in Zoom
and that way we'll be able to keep them
separate from
the chat stream
we'll be taking the Q a toward the end
of the presentation so
okay and here we go
all right so we're here today get
started for a career overview and we're
going to be looking at the field of data
science
and we've invited ganapati of Ford Motor
Company it's a leading practitioner and
manager in the area and tell you about
the
state of the
field of data science and
how to pursue career opportunities in it
what what kind of roles there are
things you need to know about that so
I'm going to
let cartridge introduce himself as he
shares his screen
yes thank you thank you Stuart for uh
inviting me for this webinar
so maybe I will share my screen
so yeah so good good morning uh good
evening everyone so whoever uh wherever
you are all from I see people joining in
from different geography so
thank you for joining this session
um I hope it's you guys find it useful
and please feel free to send any
questions I will also possibly share my
contact towards the end of the webinar
and you can email me feel free to email
me any doubts that you may have
so to start with almost uh the
this this webinar is more about uh why
why we need to choose a career in data
science uh so taken I'm uh taken almost
10 years back when I was trying to get
into the field of uh data science and
analytics uh so I I have a background in
computer science engineering and then I
did my MBA and I started off as a
programmer working for IT services
companies when mainly in the banking
industry so uh but I you know over a
period of time I wanted to move into the
data science field and it there were
certain things that helped me get there
certain skills that helped me get there
and the reason I'm saying this is there
are certain questions uh that I
frequently get from people either on
LinkedIn or in personal personally they
just reach out to me over email
so some of the questions are pertinent
to that so yeah so a quick background
about me I have totally about 18 years
of experience uh mainly about 12 years
mainly in analytics and data science I
have worked for uh
large services company as well as
product companies startups managed data
science teams and yeah I have mainly
worked across different domains so
that's something uh that uh I like
because I did not stick to one specific
domain but across domain so I got to
understand a bit of
uh many domains so
yeah so today this is the agenda how we
will uh start with so I'll give a big
overview of data science uh incidentally
I did a webinar last year somewhere
around August so some of the content may
be similar there are some new content I
have added so mainly this about why I
chose a career in data science and how
can you how can you get into this field
of data science I assume many of you are
uh either uh fresh from college or you
are saying uh middleman management role
uh and trying to get in today's data
science right and you're also trying to
understand what are the different roles
what are the skills that require
so these are some things I'll cover
during the course of this meeting and
like Stuart said if there are any
questions you can let us know I would be
glad to take them if not if I'm not able
to answer I can even you can even send
it to me over email and I'll be glad to
address that
yeah so before we start uh just wanted
to share this interesting quote uh so
this was shared by andrage karpathy uh
his uh some of you may know him so he's
an authority in the field of uh a
artificial intelligence and he was the
director at Tesla AI uh he was also one
of the founding members of open a which
uh as you know was uh behind the latest
uh breakthrough findings the chat GPT
and the gpt4 which is uh creating quite
quite some noise in the industry and
people are having different questions
about it how to use that so this was a
quote that
he shared on Twitter the English is the
hottest new programming language so uh
just a quick overview why he said this
is uh uh we are getting to a stage where
just like using chat GPT uh instead of
focusing more on the coding side people
are going to focus more on the
application side and uh
some of the tools like chat GPT or gpt4
it's going to make it easier for people
right so it can be as simple as typing
in saying what you want and say a
website gets built for you right rather
than sit and code learn web development
so that's just an example I could give
so I will address this uh I'll speak
about chat GPT and gpt4 none of the
subsequent slides
yeah to start off with what is data
science so uh data science a data
scientist generally it would be a
combination of uh multiple skills mainly
it should be good at programming he
should have good idea of the business
domain and also he should have a good
idea of statistics and the math side of
uh things right so how things work how
the algorithms work
some of you may have maybe knowing there
are a bunch of algorithms uh say machine
learning algorithms or deep learning
algorithms that are most commonly used
and a knowledge of math statistic cell
is uh this a must to understand that
decode that and if you are trying to
solve a problem if you are trying to say
improve a model these are some areas
that will definitely help you get there
and again I will let you know what are
the key areas to focus on in terms of if
you are looking for interview
preparation what are some areas that you
can focus on
yeah so again this is a quick uh
timeline of the evolution and
this is not in order this is not in
sequence uh as I mentioned before uh so
the term machine learning it was found
somewhere around in the 1950s uh by a
person named Arthur and since then that
has uh even though it has been around
for quite some time it did not uh create
the kind of uh impact it's currently
creating more because the kind of
computing that was available at the time
uh uh was not as powerful as what it is
currently uh for example you know there
are there were super computers
mainframes uh somewhere in the 1960s 70s
and uh
the kind of computing for we have in our
mobile phones far exceeded what we had
in the super computers right so uh this
was early age where these kind of
algorithms were being worked on like
linear regression logistic regression
and so on and another is the database
the database manage rdbms the relational
database data warehouse so these were
one more of the foundations that helped
in Us in ultimately getting into
analytics data science and help
different organizations right and cloud
computing of course
formerly AWS was launched somewhere
around 2006 that's when cloud computing
caught up uh and subsequently companies
like Microsoft and Google got into cloud
computing as well started offering their
own Services based on that and yeah we
also had machine learning libraries
python you may have used a scale on
which is uh most frequently used Library
commonly used uh similarly Hadoop that's
one more uh one more of uh
something that was introduced in the
early between 2000 to 2010 again that's
a set of projects within Hadoop so it's
not it's an ecosystem where you have
different projects like high uh Hive and
hits hedge base and so on so had open
itself is a ecosystem that in turn helps
solve big data and any issues related to
Big Data so that's been one of the core
for say building a data warehouse or a
data Lake
and you may have also heard something
called as nosql so SQL is structured
query language nosql is not only
structured query language so in a way
you can think of no SQL as non-tabular
data so SQL typically handles tabular
data row columns and most structured a
schema with column names but nosql does
not uh conform to all this so it could
be more like columnar data and
unstructured data that's being held in
nosql some of these new age companies
e-commerce companies they use a lot of
nosql database starting from say
Facebook Google and so on so uh
so yeah that's another important in uh
technology that was introduced and of
course the Deep learning libraries
you may know tensorflow Fighters they
were
beginning to get traction during this
time especially in the last 10 years we
see quite a lot of traction so tensor
tensorflow is open source by Google and
pytots was open source again people tend
to use both of these for their project
and research purposes
so like I said this is not in a
particular order or it's not in a
particular you need not have to treat
everything as one following other or
equally spaced so it's more like uh an
order broadly how it was uh what are the
Technologies broadly available that has
helped us reach the current states
so I'll go into some examples or
applications of data science so again
just to clarify this webinar is more
about why you may need to get into the
data science field and I would say the
simple answer is because it's an
exciting field
that's what I feel and one of the
reasons it excites me because as you
know we it started have been in this for
a little more than 10 years and it
started on a relatively small scale you
need not have you need not have the kind
of skills you have you may need
currently it was more restricted to
model building and model evaluation but
currently it has taken a much larger
role which I will talk through during
the subsequent slides
so in terms of applications there are
these are some of the applications
mainly I have just taken example of the
banking Financial Services e-commerce
and Manufacturing so again in banking
Financial Services as you know fraud
detection so you may have seen cases
where when you say swipe a card at a
particular place or above a certain
limit you get a call immediately asking
whether was it really you who did that
transaction similarly credit to the
score when you go to a bank to get a
loan
these are some applications on the
banking Financial Services side and
e-commerce e-commerce again it there's a
lot of machine learning and AI That's
being used uh so whatever I pointed here
are a few of those recommendation
engines one of the uh most common ones
you all would have used e-commerce sites
and whenever you look at a product you
would see uh other products being
recommended at the bottom or on the site
saying similar items or people similar
to you looked at these products so those
are recommendation engines and a simple
algorithm that was used is collaboration
collaborative filtering uh to identify
who are the users similar to you and
what kind of products can we suggest
right uh and recommendation engine plays
a very big role in sales at companies
um because it causes what they call as
say upsell or cross-sell of products and
say it leads to at least 20 increase in
the revenue of companies
another area is manufacturing so
manufacturing is more uh
less digital area uh so but still uh
analytics and data science it's being
used there some of which I have
highlighted here for example
supply chain optimization so supply
chain is as you know how do you Source
things from the supplier to the packager
to all the way to the end customer right
so how do you maintain the right level
of inventory how do you ensure there is
not much delay how do you cut down the
kind of delays that happen and reduce
the latency whenever you place certain
orders right so again supply chain is
across uh different domains it could be
automative it could be fmcg so any of
these domains all of these may need
supplates in optimization another
crucial thing is forecasting so
forecasting is mainly used to identify
what are the
what is the expected uh uh for expected
demand of a particular product so again
there is a host of algorithms used uh
for that purpose but it again plays a
very crucial role because uh the
requirement as you know there are
seasons to give you an example there are
seasons when uh when the demand for
products may be really high the sales
would be high for example say a festival
season like Christmas or New Year when
sales uh is uh multiple times of what it
is during normal days so in a way
forecasting helps to stop the right set
of inventory for different companies
and these are some applications in daily
life so it's not that a or machine
learning is being used only in very
Niche areas it's also being used in our
day-to-day applications of course Google
is an obvious use case and swiggy swigis
uh for people who don't know sweetie is
a food delivery company in India so very
simply it helps in say providing the
right results based on the set of
parameters for example if you are
ordering something from a specific
location it's very important to see who
is the partner delivery partner and
which are the restaurants close by right
so in a way you would want to assign
someone who is close by as a delivery
partner so uh that's one way it helps
also like I said earlier recommendation
or suggestions so if you order a food it
also suggests others that are being
bought similarly Uber as you guys know
it's being used world over and
it's one of the interesting uh Concepts
was search pricing so again it's a
concept where you you try to match
demand and supply and you try to vary
the price you charge based on the demand
so when demand is far outstrips the
supply you would want to increase the
price like in Peak cars and we would
want to do the other way whenever the
demand is slow
and similarly Netflix again like I said
in e-commerce companies many of you
would have used Netflix so whenever you
watch a particular movie again you would
see recommendations at the bottom of the
screen uh so either it could be let's
say you watch a particular uh
particular science fiction movie let's
say so you could either see a
recommendations related to science
fiction or it could be movies that the
same actor had acted right so uh it
would think that you may like that
specific actor or you may like the
director who directed that movie so
that's simplifying it there are other
things to consider but very simply
that's our recommendations work in
general
so yeah so uh since we have been talking
about data science and uh again it will
be incomplete without speaking about
GPT chat GPT and gpt4 uh which has been
uh creating a lot of excitement
currently and also some kind of anxiety
among people so the anxiety because
people say that chat GPT made or rather
applications that evolve chat Zippity
may be the starting point there are
other uh algorithms set to level over a
period of time and uh that may
ultimately take away a lot of jobs
but we also see the benefits so
what I've highlighted here is an example
it's hardly I would say three or four
months since chat GPT came out and
gpt4 its new variant so again it's uh
much much better GPT 4 is like a family
of algorithms and it's doing much better
than chat GPT uh and this uh these
algorithms are already being used
actively it's not like uh we are
planning sometime in the future for
example Khan Academy is uh online uh
learning platform so they have started
using the screenshot that you see as an
example where they try to use uh like
something like a chat bot to interact
and help students to understand the
concepts answer questions in a better
way right
the other one is another example of its
application is Microsoft 365 so they
have introduced something called Copilot
which in a way is integrating chat GPT
into uh Microsoft products for example
say Microsoft Word or office Excel
PowerPoint right any of this if you if
you want to test it out you can go to uh
say Google sheets online uh or you could
even if you have MS word you can
you can test that out there as well so
similar to what is being shown here you
can generate content you can type in
what you want and the content will be
automatically generated right so that's
another area it's being actively so as
you know
Microsoft owns a big part of the open a
which had
founded a chat GPT and the set of
algorithms
yeah so moving next uh I wanted to give
an overview about what are the steps
mainly in what the reason is since I
will tell you guys about the roles that
are available in data science I wanted
to say what is the steps generally in
data science or machine learning model
building so what you see here is
generally a life cycle of how data is
being used
so starting from the left uh data
engineering so that is where data
ingestion so you would have data from
different uh applications say you are in
a specific bank or say you're in a
specific Manufacturing Company you have
data in different sources and how to
integrate the data so data data
ingestion effectively means bringing
that data and putting in a particular
place right and very simple terms that's
what it means and as you know you cannot
data you cannot use data as it is you
have to process transform into a
particular form so that's pre-processing
and you have to store it somewhere so
which database do you store is it Hadoop
or is it any other
rdbms that you store that the next is
data analysis so
step one is getting data step two is
understanding data and getting some
insights so here this is one of the very
crucial steps because you try to
understand uh what is what lies in the
data what are the insights uh that are
available in the data right so because
without understanding that uh you may
not be able to proceed further say with
the model development or deployment
so the next step would be model
development some of you may have may be
knowing these steps of feature
engineering how do you transform the
variables that you need understanding
which are the variables you need and
then how do you transform it in a form
such that it can help build a robust
model right so that's feature
engineering model training again as you
know you take a data you train it using
a specific algorithm same random forest
or XT boost and model evaluation so you
test how well your model is doing
and you select the best one right so you
ensure that your model does not have any
kind of uh bias or variance issue uh you
test certain metrics and see that it's
doing well on all those parameters
and the next one the last especially the
fourth one that you see here ml
engineering this is something that has
evolved a lot uh what you see here model
development has traditionally been there
for a long time but engineering is
while you develop a model so how do you
deploy it how you create an
enterprise-wide solution
so some of you may be working in ID and
you must have deployed production grade
applications as you understand there is
a set of requirements that you need
while you develop a say a web web
application you try to use it somewhere
on your local that's a different thing
but when you are deploying in a
production grade environment so they are
real customers come in uh there may be
high traffic and uh the kind of speed at
which people get responses may be
required the application should not be
down so all this
partly is being handled by ml
engineering so ml engineering would
cover model serving so model serving is
think of you have deployed a model and
it starts predicting so let's say
whenever a customer walks in a bank he
asks for uh he applies for a loan and uh
you kind of you try to check what is
this code let's take a simple example so
model serving would just say Okay given
this set of parameters what is the uh
chance of this customer defaulting on
payment so it's for that's an example of
credit scoring and that's being that's
where it tries to predict on a real data
so model deployment model monitoring
test to ensure that your model performs
well so if you deploy a model over a
period of time say six months or one
year later you have to ensure that your
model does not deteriorate and
performance certain metrics that you
need to keep in place
and finally insights and visualization
so again this is what is served in the
end to the business so you can think of
the last player as what maybe the
business sees or the business integrates
so you can think of it as apis that are
developed that in turn help call the
machine learning models or you can think
of it as say dashboards that business
users try to consume
right so this is broadly the set of
steps
the reason I gave this is to give you an
overview uh of what is required and then
now I will give you an idea of what are
the roles that are available in um
in this field
so again this is not an exhaustive list
where I just put together the most
common ones easy ones there are
definitely other roles uh some of it may
be more technical some of it may be less
technical but these are the most
frequent ones so data analyst again he's
this is a role that involves a good
understanding of SQL Excel and a good
business understanding uh and use of
certain mathematical techniques to
derive insights from data and provide to
the executive team right senior
leadership
and data scientists I would say that's
like a much more uh expanded version of
a data analyst so data scientist like I
said is needs many more skills than what
a data analyst have for example he may
need to know machine learning models he
may need to know how to deploy a model
you may need to know how to get in the
right data transform the data to a
specific form so data scientists you can
think of almost someone who has multiple
skills more than what a data analyst has
so yeah that's mainly the difference
between the two business intelligence
that is more on the reporting side or
dashboards that the business may want to
look at so the End Business generally
they track metrics for example they
would want to say how many views for a
e-commerce company would want to say how
many views did our website get yesterday
and they may track this on a daily basis
so business intelligence tools help you
to do that common exam
and so on so these are click view
Tableau these are some examples of
business intelligence tools
the next one is ml op so
uh I think some of you may have heard
this term so mlops is a variant of
devops so uh just like devops is a
combination of development and operation
so how you productionize what has been
developed similarly mlopsis how do you
productionize the models that have been
developed and like I said earlier how do
you ensure they are able to run in a
production grade environment right
without much hassles so that is ml Ops
again this role uh sometimes this role
is combined with the data scientist role
some companies keep this separate uh
some companies
combine the data scientist as well as
the envelopes role they call them ml
engineer so like I said a broad range of
skills are required how to program
develop a modulus one
but also some knowledge on skills like
say Docker kubernetes how to
containerize your applications and CI CD
understanding of those Concepts and how
they actually work understanding of
GitHub Version Control how do you look
at all this right so these are some
expectations from an ml Ops engineer and
finally data engineer so like I said
data engineer would fall under the
category of data engineering so this is
where he would lift most part that I
said data ingestion and uh data
pre-processing so that's where this data
engineer would mainly be helpful again
the kind of skills required is a bit
different even something like
understanding of Big Data Technologies
like spark or say Informatica so
Informatica is what is called a ETL tool
so basically it pulls data from The
Source transforms it and lands it in the
database so uh so that is one of some of
the tools that a data engineer is
expected to know SQL that's another
important uh skill that he needs to have
so moving on
um yeah so I added this because uh I
these roles that I mentioned have been
there around uh traditionally but there
may be newer rules that may come up as
well for example going back to what we
were speaking about the GPT
there is a new role that's coming up
again it's not across uh companies but
the role is called prompt engineer as
being said so uh so prompt engineer is
someone who has the name says uh
provides the right set of inputs to
something like uh chat GPT UA
and it's to ensure in a way it's to
ensure you get the kind of output that
you require right so if your goal is to
write taking an example if your goal is
to write a blog for a company
your product engineer May provide the
right set of inputs so this inputs can
be plain English you don't need any idea
of coding you don't need coding skills
so with the UI interface uh you can
input your uh what your requirements in
plain English so that's where I was
referring to going back to what Andres
karpati was mentioning English is the
new uh hottest new programming language
so understanding how a systems work at
the same time ensuring you know how to
connect that to business is another
important skill
uh yeah so these are some new rules uh
we expect new rules to evolve uh and the
reason I'm saying is uh uh the the
generation of coding uh developing
something from scratch is uh slowly
being replaced by say low code or no
code applications
to so for people who do not have that
much of coding experience uh you have
low code or no code application where uh
even even a even someone with a basic
understanding of the platform will be
able to uh develop a model uh and gets
to do some predictions right to give an
example
yeah so coming to key skills for a
career in data science so like I said
earlier there are three broad areas
the math part uh essentially it's about
linear algebra calculus statistics so
initially it may look a bit to me uh but
yeah this is one of the foundations of
uh uh a and machine learning data
science so uh you may need to brush up
on these Concepts software engineering
like I said
pain in software engineering it I have
included a lot of uh model building
requirements so uh like software engine
I think I combined machine learning as
well as
the software engineering envelopes part
of it yeah so programming language
understanding of programming language
you can pick up a simple programming
language like python you have R which is
another statistical programming language
so you can pick up such kind of uh
languages experiment with it for fun you
can just build your own applications uh
so there are packages libraries
available you know in open and you can
try using that and build your own
application so that's more like a fun
project you can do not to get an
understanding of how things work
and similarly like I said scikit-learn
tensorflow Fighters are all libraries ML
and AI libraries that you can that's
most frequently used in the industry
and another important uh thing is the
business understanding and critical
thinking so this is something that uh
even if you attend interviews there's
something that people expect a lot uh
and this is something you may need to
brush while programming and uh the math
side is one uh but uh people expect they
in interviews again I will cover what
are the areas where generally the
interviewers would question you and what
are areas where you may need to prepare
so along with the other skills business
understanding and also critical thinking
uh is something that's required and of
course data science being an evolving
field you may have to it involves
lifelong learning and keeping yourself
updated
yeah so uh again I included this slide
because uh I think one of the questions
I get most often is I am working in a
specific industry so how do I which is
not in data science how do I move into
data science
um and what are some ways I can try
doing it right so that's the reason I
included a slide I expect some even some
questions around this so uh what I would
suggest or recommend is if you some of
you are in it you can look at how you
can use your skills uh complementary
skills where you can you know transition
into data science so uh just to give you
an idea uh companies look for people who
are uh good at already have the skills
or if they feel someone can pick up
those skills they provide them
opportunities as well and to do that you
can see what skill do you currently have
and where can you really help or how can
you what kind of transition can you make
into data science right so to take an
example SQL Developer so let's say you
know SQL you know programming uh if you
are trying to get into data science you
can possibly move to a data engineer
role again SQL is like a foundational
skill uh so once you move into this kind
of a role uh you'll get an idea how
things work and then you can ultimately
move into say more uh uh kind of into
machine learning or a related uh
projects similarly devops some of you
may have worked in devops devops again
is a critical uh skill that's required
so people in devops would find
transitioning to mlops uh relatively
easier
and organizations require this this is
Enterprise machine learning models or
that's something that organizations
focus a lot and this is a skill that can
help you move to ml Ops and again like I
said if you want to get into a different
field once you are established in
envelopes that's something you can do
and also uh internal rotation so if you
are working in a company and if it's a
large company there are opportunities
that generally come up uh say you're
working in a I.T services company and
you are working in a specific uh domain
uh you can reach out to the analytics uh
Department look for any openings
generally they provide internal opening
so that's a very good bet how you can
move internally within the organization
I'm saying this because if you start
looking out one of the questions that
may come up as what experience do you
have in this field and so you may have
to start from scratch almost like you
have to prove that you are good that
this to a different company but if it's
internal uh you can even use the help of
someone like your manager if you have if
you can get this recommendation then uh
you can even use that as a way to get
into the data science field
another important thing is personal
project so uh while certifications are
one but keeping personal projects like I
said so do some fun projects on the side
take NLP models or they take any kind of
computer vision models uh and have a
GitHub repository for yourself put it on
your resume put it on your LinkedIn
profiles because when uh people who want
to hire they look at these and your
projects your site projects are
impressive it tells that you're really
interested in uh in this field and this
role right so this one more uh advice I
had
in terms of interview expectations these
are some five areas that you can broadly
look at and also where typically the
questions come from and also I've
included some ways to prepare or how to
uh understand what kind of interviews so
mentorship the reason I say is I uh I
benefited a lot from this and I still
continue to reach out to people if I
need to understand or learn something
and people are ready to help not
everyone but there are people who would
definitely help you you can either reach
out through Linkedin your personal
contacts and to give a very good
perspective about what is required
the second is understanding algorithms
of course this is one question that will
come up in the interviews they may ask
you about say explain the XT boost
algorithm explain random Forest what is
the difference between the two when do
you use these right some of these common
questions and similarly case study
scenario so that's one more uh area that
uh generally the questions come along so
they may give you a scenario a
hypothetical scenario where uh they say
this is the data that's available for
example like retail store or say fmcg
industry banking industry this is the
data that's available
and uh how would you handle this problem
for example I want to
identify the most valuable customers so
which data would you pick what kind of
model would you build again this is a
way to test your thinking process
there's no right or wrong answer but uh
try to give your best yeah that will
give an idea of how you think on your
feed
similarly data oriented thought process
so like I said the data science Industry
while programming this that's one part
of it but thinking in terms of how which
data to use how to use that's another
critical skill uh which ultimately the
organizations look so
there are a lot of resources how you can
that you can refer to to fine-tune the
skills something like kaggle if you go
on kaggle there are tons of Open Source
uh
projects that are being done fun
projects it could be simple uh machine
learning models to computer vision
models NLP models so that's a place
where you can you don't even need to set
up an environment it has environment set
up there you can just log in and you can
start coding in the browser right so you
can also know where you're going wrong
so it's another fun way to learn
and similarly finally pick some key
projects which are technically intensive
that you have done in the past
so that it will show what kind of uh how
impactful your work has been
yeah so I spoke about the practicing
coding learning coding so these are some
top sites I have used a few the others I
had to just search and get it like
hacker rank lead code these are some
excellent sites where you can learn
programming online
uh Again YouTube that's something I did
not include but another excellent
resource you see a lot of free resources
uh even courses 10 hour courses 15 hour
courses being taught uh all for free on
YouTube right so these are some sites
you can refer to
some good books I have referred to some
of these books for understanding these
are some of the good books again you
could search and try starting with a few
of them uh so that will help
and yes of course you have like I said
uh
online portals or other open courses
Khan academies one and some of these
other websites these are some that you
can refer to
so yeah so that's uh it from my side I
try to cover most of what was asked uh
and uh yeah you can like I said you can
reach out to me at this mail address
again if you have a specific question
please feel free to
[Music]
share it with me again given time
constraints it may there may be some
delay in responding but I will try to
respond uh as at the earliest
yeah so uh Stuart uh is over to you is
there any other areas that would like to
cover
no I think we'll get to the questions
and the answers
yeah okay so
I'm gonna take back the screen sharing
questions and answers but we don't need
to watch the slide while we're doing
that so I'll stop that
and so we have a number of questions
that came in through the chat as well as
through the Q a so we'll try to get to
many of these as possible and the time
allowed
um
so here's a question that relates to
what you're saying about chat GPT
what are the implications of using chat
GPT for someone learning programming
should you be dependent upon using it if
the aim is to learn
yes so uh that's a good question uh and
this was something I was playing around
with as well looking at chat Deputy one
if you're learning programming I would
say please try it out chat GPT so chat
GPT maybe an a model but you can learn
programming through chat GPT as well for
example you could just say I have seen
cases where people
in less than a half they have built a
website for themselves by just asking
the right questions to chat GPT like I
said simple English statements asking
for what type of code is required but
the catch here is uh there are a lot of
bugs or errors identified it's not 100
perfect but the amazing thing is how
effective it is it I would say it covers
almost 70 80 percent of what we require
there are definitely uh areas that they
need to still work on and I'm pretty
sure with the speed at which things are
changing uh so to answer your question
yes you can use chat GPT for example you
could simply say uh can you write a for
Loop giving an example in Python how do
I write a particular JavaScript function
in uh that all of this the answers
should be shown you can feed in a code
and you can you you can ask can you
explain what is happening in the code
right so it works both ways it will give
you code or it can take your code and
tell you what is happening so
just a few of them again the kind of
applications are numerous so yeah so you
should try using it rather than share
what uh what it may do you may need to
use it understand and then in a way try
and play around with such kind of tools
thank you
we have a question from Raj who's asked
can a student from a non-engineering
background make a successful career in
data science
become a data scientist and how should
that person approach
um
doing that yes yes so uh again since you
said non-engineering I uh there are
multiple Fields people from multiple
Fields who have become data scientists I
have seen a lot of people engineering is
one small subset of it something like a
statistics people with the background in
statistics math background
and many more right so engineering is
not a must a good understanding of math
and I see people pick up of course
programming and other skills that's
required and the way you should approach
it is depending on your background so
like I said if you are a statistics have
a statistic background and you're not
very comfortable with programming you
can start with something like SQL python
easy to pick up easy to start start with
some small site projects and also look
at internships how you can get an
internship opportunity so that that will
help you get a tofold in this industry
okay thank you um you had covered this a
bit in your presentation we have still a
couple questions on it about the the
difference between a data analytics and
data science
the distinction between the two
yes so like I said data analytics uh
again as a smaller area it is not as
intensive in terms of programming so
both try to make sense of data derive
insights but data science has evolved a
lot more in terms of the expectation the
skill set uh like I said the engineering
software engineering part of it is a a
big area that needs to be covered uh ml
Ops and so on data analytics simply
could be uh taking data creating reports
for your leadership sharing your
insights and at times maybe creating
simple models like linear regression
logistic but data science involves much
more than that so like I said it's a
combination of engineering software
engineering plus math plus business
right so that's the way you can it's
much more evolved than data analytics
um is it fair to say that
data scientists build uh the the models
that data analysts then use to interpret
the data
yes so that is one of the applications
uh uh like I said the data scientists
one of the key things is model building
uh and how do they deploy models so
machine learning models which learn from
data and do the predictions going
forward right so like you said it can be
something that the data analysts can
take as an input
cool uh we have a question from someone
who apparently just completed I believe
the 12th boards um which I assume means
that they
completed secondary school and they want
to know if it should be uh they should
look at becoming a data scientist
through a BCA degree or are there other
courses approaches that they can take
yeah I I can like I said earlier
um and BCA I have seen MCA candidates
quite a number of MCA candidates have
become data scientists in my team so
that could be one option uh doing a
masters in computer application or like
I said doing a course in math and
statistics that could be something that
will really help if you can
get into a good uh and you get into a
good college uh and do a course and say
math and Stat uh so that will give a
very good foundation understanding of
the concepts that you would learn in a
and ml uh again engineering could be one
of them uh not a must I have seen MBA
candidates uh also entering this MBA
candidates they have us they are very
good in business interfacing business
insights right so that could be one more
area so broadly these are areas where I
have seen candidates
who become data scientists thank you
um we had a question somebody who would
like a definitional question but what's
the difference between SQL and MySQL and
then maybe you can mention also what
nosql is
yes so MySQL is one specific so SQL is a
very uh uh in generic industry terms of
structured query language as it states
so how do you read data write data uh
they call it Cru decrued operations uh
so how do you read write data and
databases so MySQL is one particular uh
software that's available uh for Rd for
a database Management Systems other
things are you may know oracle teradata
uh SQL Server these are some other uh
softwares that also use sequence right
so yes SQL is a more industry term and
MySQL is a specific software and nosql
is a completely different thing so uh
nosql is more about SQL is about tabular
data you can think of SQL like an Excel
sheet with rows and columns nosql is for
example if you have data from a website
right how do you dump data so columnar
data documents right unstructured data
so that's mainly what nosql is used and
it also helps in processing speed
yeah we have a question from somebody
who wants to understand the difference
between data analyst and business
analyst
yes so business analyst is more uh
explained about data analysts business
analyst is uh less about uh less about
getting insights from data so uh I have
been a business analyst as well it's
more about business analyst could be in
any field for example even and say it uh
uh Industries they may have they may
have business analysts so it's more
about how you do you uh how do you
provide the functional requirements for
businesses to the technical thing so
like an interface between the technical
team and the business so in a way he
tries to structure what is required what
is the gaps and what do the technical
teams really need to do so try to
convert and take down the functional
specifications
there's several questions having to do
with people coming from other Industries
and it kind of relates to the earlier
question from the student which is or
from the non-engineering person as well
um is there a particular path that you
recommend for somebody who's coming from
a different background so we have some
people from microbiology from content
writing that type of thing
okay so
um like I said um mainly I've seen uh
two areas one two or three areas say
there's someone with a stacked
background a business uh a degree in
business or someone with an engineering
background uh if you are from a specific
domain uh like in microbiology you can
if you are if you want to pursue a
career in that field you can use your
domain knowledge for doing that uh I
like I said business is one part of data
science so you have to see how
interested you are in programming uh
everyone may not find programming easy
or they may not like programming so you
have to see is that something you like
and similarly the math
part of it right is that something
you're able to pick up and understand uh
so yeah so if uh again depending on
whichever domain you are there may be
requirements uh but the catch is
sometimes some domains are quite broad
may have a higher requirement uh some
domains are very Niche right so you have
to see where you can accordingly get
into it and similarly doing a course or
doing a certification that could be
something that people can try for
example uh there are
courses that are provided say six month
or one year course so that's something
that you can also try so that uh you
dedicate some time just to understand it
and in the end you uh based on that you
can pitch to different companies so that
is one more option and you may also get
placement assistance from these
companies when you do core system
you have a application question from a
Content writer who is going into SEO and
smm and um
he's curious to know what
or he or she is curious to know what
kind of data
one would analyze for this role and and
you might mention
chat GPT as a potential Avenue for that
as well
yes so content writer is something very
similar to what I mentioned one of the
applications of GPT so
um yeah again depends on if I understand
the question correct uh
so yeah again the kind of keywords that
is being used
or you you very simply said you're a
Content writer so you may be knowing how
to uh how to structure your writing in a
way that can get more views so if you
are developing a website how to
structure your content in a particular
format so how do you use such tools like
GPT or any of these they call it
generative a so like something that
generates content for uh end users so
can you enhance your content writing or
SEO and CMM skills using uh such kind of
tools and this is where something like
prompt engineering comes maybe you may
need to do you can do some research that
prompt engineering is uh more about how
do I give the right input and how do I
extract the right output right so uh
let's say you ask some some you provide
a sentence uh in English
and you just type in Spanish right so
all it will do is translate it uh to uh
Spanish uh but let's say you provide
some other input right so uh let's say
you want to say how do I generate
content for the content from this
sentence so all these are done through
prompts uh prompts are again like
keywords and you may need to understand
that so that I can see content writing
uh such kind of tools will be a good one
to try out sure and there's an old
expression that if you want better
answers you have to ask better questions
and that precisely what uh prompt
engineering is so
um
Juliet asked if there are any companies
you can recommend for internships
come to mind
I ended up quite a number of them
um I mean generally what I do whenever I
someone requests me for
say an internship I generally circulate
within my uh within my alumni group and
more often than not I at least get two
or two leads or three leads it can vary
anything from Iron I don't know which
geography you're from but it can vary
anything from a small startup to large
companies again large companies I I
mentioned in one of the previous uh
webinars the problem with large
companies is they have a very fixed uh
hiring pattern so they have a policy
that they can only pick people from
certain geography from certain colleges
but startups they look for candidates
who can help them out they're very not
so
hierarchical uh as large companies so I
would say uh trying internships at
smaller companies through your contacts
uh
I mean like I said depending on which
geography which country you are in you
can go through some of the contacts
research on LinkedIn uh I mean yeah that
that's the advice I have
um
we had a question from ahmadu who asks
if she has a good background in in
programming and I assume that he would
like to continue emphasizing programming
in his career
which of the data science roles are most
suited we'll use that skill most
yes so again depends uh so like you said
uh since you are interested in
programming uh something like an ml
engineer could be a
um would be something that you can try
and if you have deployed the
applications production grade
applications ml Ops could be something
you can try uh again if math is
something like I said
math is something that uh is something
that you are not very interested in you
can look at roles like enamel Ops role
or even a data engineer role uh for
example data engineer role more requires
does not require as much math it's more
about understanding the data using tools
like say Informatica or even spark like
big data Technologies for uh Landing the
data which in turn is being used by uh
the other data centers right so those
are some roles you can definitely try
yeah that's
um
and yeah I think your slide the cartoon
slide touched on this and uh well asks
if development of generative AI is ever
going to replace data scientists
uh okay so yes that's a question that uh
is something that's being asked
frequently so definitely I think there
is one saying uh that's uh going that's
uh that is being said so uh uh
generative way may not replace uh
employees but uh it is it will replace
people who do not know how to use a
right so rather than think in terms of I
am a data centers will it replace me you
have to think
how do I do I understand this and how
can I use it like someone said they are
content writer they will definitely
benefit from understanding how to use
chat GPT for their own case right so if
you are able to help organization uh
improve their productivity do things
much faster just by using these tools
then definitely you will be someone whom
people will be hiring Your Role may
change but like I said uh the amount of
coding required is all that's a pattern
that I see people amount of coding
required is slowly coming down like
people are going to know code low code
Technologies so yeah the kind of roles
can really differ I I was talking about
chat GPT but even on the other side you
have computer vision generative way can
be you can generate images generate
images of people who do not exist
generate new kind of Photography right
any any of these things so uh yeah the
time like that's why I said the type of
roles will change given uh people are
evolving from coding to uh more the
business applications and kind of
breakthroughs we have done thank you
um we have a question from a
um
University student in mathematics and
computer science and asking for
recommendations of uh
what courses they can take in their
program to prepare to be a data
scientist
so okay so they have if I understand
your question correctly they have a
background mathematics and computer
scientists that's what they're studying
in University now yes
they want to know how to become a data
science while they're well they're doing
that studying
yeah so I think that what the course I
don't know uh what's uh the kind of
subjects that are being covered but I
think math and computer science almost
covers uh good uh amount of what's
required in data science and uh yeah try
to like I said uh so you may know
programming already start developing
some side projects working on site
projects uh and there are some specific
courses like you can focus on ML the
machine learning related courses that
can move you to help you get into this
field right and of course look at
internships uh like I said earlier try
to go through your contacts or LinkedIn
these are some good places to
start off in this field
we have someone who's currently an m e
specialist and like to know how data
analysis Works uh
is that a good transition to Pivot into
or is it something that would be a skill
set to add to
sorry so what is
that I don't know
know what M A is which is a Bridges and
acquisition so maybe our uh okay or
learner or attendee will clarify so
let's move on
um
it's a it's a short-term course
certificate sufficient for your CV in
data science or what else do you need to
build out your CV
yeah so again this is a frequent
question and uh something that I should
uh clarify so uh uh short-term
certificates getting a certificate
spending time getting a certificate is
relatively easier but putting in the
time and the understanding uh developing
the expertise to uh really think in in
terms of data and how can I use this
data to build interesting applications
that's a completely different skill so
getting certificate alone will not be
enough in fact these days you can get
online certificates or so but companies
look for people how do they apply right
so even if you have multiple
certificates they are going to ask
questions about uh what type of projects
have you built if you are if you don't
have a background already they will ask
you specific questions on the ml
algorithms programming and so on so yeah
I would say course certificate is
relatively for knowledge that's
something that you can do but uh
definitely for uh if you are looking for
a job you may need to build projects to
get into this field okay
um
I want to reassure everybody Ross asks
if slides will be shared I'll be sending
out a link to the recording of this
session so you'll be able to see
everything and review it
cartridge is shared
um
a WS an interesting question because
um another application question is a PhD
student he's working on his thesis
and
um
he doesn't want to give his work to a
scientist or an analyst to do the
analytical part can you use chat DPT
helping his Analytics
within his thesis project
okay
so yeah again uh there are some concerns
I haven't I'm not fully aware but there
are some concerns privacy concerns that
uh if people put their data on chat GPT
in a way it can be used in some form so
uh again I see that you are trying to
look for privacy of your thesis work but
uh I mean you can take a call you can
see you do not give any uh sensitive
information because I see there are
cases where people feed in uh data into
chat GPT and that gets used in a form
they don't want to for example someone
may input company specific information
and the information is being used to uh
all over right so remember that the data
is what has been used historical data is
used to train these models so maybe the
data that you feed in will also be part
of uh this model
and it sounds like
what uh W is looking for is assistance
with techniques of analysis and maybe
asking the questions
in that form of what's the best way to
do this analysis or how would I do this
analysis might be helpful rather than
asking chat GPT to do the analysis for
you we have uh
the the last couple of questions and I
know there were a number in the chat
that we don't have time to get to but
um the last couple of questions uh I'll
combine them in interviews
um
will people be asking about math and
python one of the
coding languages that people need when
when they're going to apply for data
science jobs
yes math like I said understand your
math is a must people will question you
on specific Concepts how the ml
algorithms work so something like basic
linear algebra calculus these are some
things you may need to know programming
of course you pick a program that's used
often python is very easy to understand
and easy to pick so uh something like
that but yeah to answer your question
you may need to know these kind of
skills okay and in business intelligence
uh business
analysts do they need to have a
programming background as well
yes so uh and it depends uh for example
some of the tools I mentioned Tableau
business intelligence is more about the
reports the dashboards that's developed
uh so uh you may need the programming it
depends on the type of tool like I said
uh business intelligence the foundation
is the data that is being prepared so
the data can be prepared by uh any other
team a very simple tool commonly used is
Excel so in Excel you have pivot charts
that are being used power bi will be one
more that's being used so yeah uh there
may be depending on the type of tool the
amount of it depends uh how much coding
depends on the type of technology that
you are using
okay and um that's all the questions we
have time for I just put your LinkedIn
uh URL into the chat for people's
references and we're going to close out
now with a really brief
um
description of one of the programs that
simply learn offers in this area
um this is an example of the kind of
thing that one can do first a question
for our audience
um what has prevented you up till now
from taking
step of
certification and data science
I'll leave this open just for another 10
seconds
so if you would get your answers in
quickly
and I'm going to close this in five
four
three
two one hit your submit button please
and here's the poll result
and the main concerns people have are
finding a program that gives them
practical experience they can use to
demonstrate their skills as well as
program that's fully comprehensive so
we'll move on to
just a brief description of this program
space of about one minute postgraduate
program in data science is available
worldwide it's targeted outside of North
America it's 11 month program that
requires about 10 hours a week it's
fully online
um it has content from IBM as part of
the program and it features live
instruction on online live virtual
classrooms
access the rest of the program is kartik
mentioned this is one of the programs
that gives you the programming
environment on your browser so you don't
have to download or set up an
environment for doing the exercises in
labs and the comprehensive curriculum
covers statistics python applications
Python and data science
basics of machine learning Tableau for
visualization and Reporting and a
Capstone project that gives you a chance
to build a solution to an industry
aligned problem that you can have in
your git portfolio that you can show off
to potential future employers along the
way you can take any of these electives
without any extra cost these are based
on your level of interest and your time
availability that you can study
analytics with Excel SQL training R
programming power bi
a deep learning with tensorflow and then
you can take master classes from Caltech
instructors as well as IBM instructors
and this is a postgraduate program that
requires you to have bachelor's degree
and a basic understanding of programming
and math but not an extensive amount of
experience
although they do recommend that you have
two or more years of work experience
that doesn't have to be in technology or
programming
um quick question for the folks in the
audience because our kick also asked
this
when we were chatting before the webinar
how much experience do you have
currently
working on your degree or have you been
working in industry for some time
and I'll leave this open for five
four three
to one
in the poll
and a little over a third of our
audience are students
the rest of you have work experience
quite a few of you have more than five
years of work experience
fairly seasoned I'm sorry I forgot to
share this so you can see the result
here
and
um
I want to mention one other part of the
program because it came up in some
questions
um
we offer career assist service not a
placement service per se but we offer
help to people in developing their job
search and their rears ongoing so we
have a ongoing webinars that help you
with career skills technology skills
overviews of the industry you also build
up a portfolio on the program of real
world projects so that you have
experience that you can show to
potential employers and for those of you
in India I'm sorry it's not available in
other
countries but in India we work with IIM
jobs to give you six months of access
their programs for the job board
resume rewriting and interview
preparation so
or a student in India
that's part of this program as well
so
I asked two questions
first one is
might you be interested in this program
and I'll just leave this open for about
10 seconds
and I'll close in three two one
and
a lot of people are so um I'll ask the
second question which is
if you are interested so something you
want to do
right away
or a little further down the road
it's open again
five four three
two one
pull
quite a few of you are interested in
doing this either immediately or the
next couple of months
and so that's excellent I will um
mention how to get involved in this
and the next cohort of classes starts at
the end of April
with an orientation session classes
immediately thereafter
the program cost is one lock 95 000 if
you are in an African country or any
other part of the world you'll want to
look at our website and I will share
with you that link and that will take
you to um I'll give you the local
cost of the program
your local area I'm going to put into
the
um
put into the chat right now
the email address that you see
the contact our learning consultants and
the URL of the program webpage
and if you would like to get a
certificate
of attendance proof of attendance for
today's session or if you are
would like us to reach out to you from a
learning Consultants
answer yes to this question and I'm
launching it now
and I'll leave this open for about 15
seconds
again if you answer yes we will send you
a proof of attendance for this session
and I'm going to close this in five four
three
two one
sure the result
about two-thirds of our audience are
interested so I will
make that available to you after this
expect that in the next day or two
at this point I want to thank